it's Friday and you know what that means
reboot mania one stinky grounded claim
and the biggest documentary in the
country for to begin for more we're
joined by a New York Times bestselling
author the will Wilder series and Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo okay
Raymond there were more reboots
announced this week yes like you know
the 90s return the 90s are back with a
vengeance up Frazier may be rebooted
charmed the show remember the three
witches they're gonna reboot that and
the biggest reboot that's causing so
much blowback Buffy the Vampire Slayer I
remember this show now Michelle you
don't remember the show I never want it
was a huge this was one in the 90s this
was one of those kind of seminal shows
that captured the zeitgeist of the time
it was a girl fighting back who could be
both beautiful and tough well well
there's a lot of ism there's a lot of
blowback because they not want to recast
Buffy as a black actress have a black
actress play the lead role and I want to
share this tweet with you this is
indicative of some of what's happening
on social media this is a staff writer
for vulture on Angelica Jade and she
writes she's an african-american writer
she says I'm not interested in seeing a
black slay or take on the role of Buffy
or even seeing gender and race bent
reboots it's boring and insulting we
deserve our own mythology that is a
great important I think take on all of
this remember a few years ago in 2014
yeah they tried to relaunch Murder She
Wrote the old Angela Lansbury show with
Octavia Spencer that went long
nowhere well Angela Lansbury said Cabot
Cove is our little world this character
is so particular to that time in place I
can't see it the fans agreed with her
that reboot dies don't work
yeah she's 94 years of age work I mean
the woman is unbelievable anyway but
well my problem with these reboots and
trying to recast them and make gender
points tell new stories for this
generation you're depriving this
generation of their characters their
stories by trying to squeeze them into
these old wineskins or old sitcoms in
this case I kind of had it with the
reason it's not like the Benetton
approach to casting it's a everyone
however if you're gonna do Star Wars the
Star Wars thinks about the worst
Everybody Loves Raymond would make a
great reboot Pattie heat and Ray Romano
if you're listening you know start right
I love that true I'm not speaking of
reboots watch now this is a curious
story where we need a reboot from last
night a spirit airplane was grounded
over what people on the plane were
calling a stinky sock smell the plane
going from New York to Fort Lauderdale
was diverted to Myrtle Beach this is no
I'm not making it here it is god bless
the worst okay
don't defame it's the worst experience
I'm sorry I've been on Spirit Airlines
before they charge you for air for God's
sake you can if you go don't breathe
bring in the Box I'm bringing the camera
next time she tries to get on out here
it's like sorry
here's know the people aren't the
passengers started complaining because
they were getting nauseous they were
getting headaches and not just a few of
them so they grounded the plane in
Myrtle Beach but when people went aboard
they couldn't find the source of the
smell and I was thinking why didn't you
check the passengers
I got a stinky sock smell have you
traveled no no in these people take
their shoes and then the so no I took a
photo of a flight from Chicago this past
week not well I didn't not the face but
just about a twenty-something had bare
feet and was putting her filthy barefoot
with toe rings on the armrest next okay
III got like a dry heave is all right
every time I fill up you know there's a
message if your truck if you're
traveling it's not your bedroom
otherwise just show up in an adult
diaper and call it a day no bathroom
either clipping the nails babies on the
pulldown tray table you say you've got a
change in somewhere this is why every
time I travel I break out those Lysol
wipes and I know you call me Felix Unger
but I scrub now travel with Raymond now
it's at the point where people asked
it is the Odd Couple throwing things all
over the place where aims like don't
move anything you gotta call it before
you you put your before we go though
before we go there's a movie that's
about to become the highest-grossing
biographic documentary in history it's
gotta be a Winston she done Churchill
Regan Laura what is it Laura it's a
beautiful day in the neighborhood a
beautiful day for a neighbor would you
be mine I hate it would you be Ron why
do you hate mister I couldn't look what
I'm doing for you today I was putting my
cardigan on just for the village I found
it Karen aides were gonna make believe
the carrot that put your part again on
Ingram you'll feel look I already feel
better here either I feel warmer you're
a cardigan person or you're not no I'm
not one this means I got my cold new
movie the new mr. Rogers movie would you
be my neighbor
this movie this movie is about to make
25 million dollars at the box office it
is the biggest documentary in the last
five years and to give you some idea Al
Gore's movie that Inconvenient Truth
Canadian box office it made three point
seven million dollars at the box office
bag and the Pope Francis movie earlier
this year
point seven million at the box office
but not why are people going to this mr.
Rogers movie innocence well I think it's
innocence decency wonderment someone who
is uplifting people and using the medium
for work just like you angry just like
the satire or cheap cynicism of our
segments this is a beautiful little town
and let me tell you about Mister Rogers
he was a Presbyterian minister who used
the medium for good he thought he could
have helped them through difficulties he
was also I discovered watching the movie
a lifelong Republican you'll be happy to
know I got a sense of that slip-on shoes
are they tie shoes I don't remember I
think he did have sip ons he would take
him up and put the tie sneakers on he
would put the sneakers on but it was a
very warm I don't hear either mister I
wasn't a mr. Raj
review kind of children were captivated
by you need a little more of that
tenderness and gentleness on TV and
non-political okay vanish that from your
war doctor do you like them you don't
like the cardigan now we expose that
cardigan